I'm Mike Magee and I'm a professor in
material science engineering at Stanford
University and I'm also a senior fellow
in the Precourt Institute for energy and
I'm the director of the energy
certificate program I have a degree in
physics from Princeton University and a
PhD in material science from University
of California Santa Barbara when I was a
graduate student I saw the opportunity
to apply to be a professor at Stanford I
was initially disappointed because it
was my dream job and I thought I was too
young but I went for it I applied and I
got it then Here I am I find solar cell
research to be fascinating because there
are so many different possible solutions
to the problem and as someone who's been
working in the field for over 15 years I
know my mind has been changed several
times on what the most promising
approach is my lab works on several
different kinds of solar cells we take a
holistic view towards it and study
everything from how they're made to how
they work to what they would cost and we
try to interact with industry to make
sure we're developing effective
solutions